and South Korea has lodged a complaint
with Israel after a planeload of South
Koreans was refused entry 12 Israeli
passengers were taken off the Korean
Airlines flight when it arrived in Tel
Aviv
but 130 other passengers were turned
back Israel is now banning South Korean
and Japanese visitors the move follows
the discovery of coronavirus among a
group of South Korean tourists who
visited Israel last week
I'll tell us how they're getting a
handle on things in in Daegu well that's
right I mean that these these measures
would be welcomed here by health
officials and hospital officials trying
to deal with these two outbreaks that
we've had we have two clusters here in
the southeast of the country that's the
main concern really for the whole of
South Korea at the moment is making sure
that these clusters do not spread here
in the city of Daegu we have one cluster
that we know is centered on a particular
Church here a number of church goers
being infected in fact they account for
just over half of the total number of
infections but in neighboring chongo
County here we've also had another
cluster that is linked to this city
where we've had a hospital that had as
the disease spread very quickly through
patients and members of staff that
hospital now is being converted being
dedicated to fighting the corona virus
many of the patients who suffered from
the corona virus the very severe
symptoms have been transferred out but
extra medical staff have now been sent
in they're converting that hospital
along with a number of other facilities
here specialist Ward's testing centers
all these different resources now being
put to try to deal with this outbreak
and of course by declaring the red alert
level the highest level that allows the
central government to direct more
resources down to this Southeast area a
moon jaein the president of South Korea
was in a very grave mood when he
announced the new measures saying that
the next few days for South Korea will
be critical saying that the country is
that a what kind of a watershed juncture
it's very important that if this is
going to be controlled then it has to be
control
at this moment calling on provinces and
also cities to take the initiative to
step up to support this effort and there
are various other measures being taken
such as schools that have been on
vacation that vacation has been extended
well into the week all the different
ways of trying to reduce the risk of
further infections trying to stop
further clusters from forming anywhere
in South Korea is there a sense of
responsibility there Rob for the the
citizens themselves to to self isolate
to do their part to try to keep this
from spreading there is when you go
around you talk to people people are
very alarmed they're very worried
fearful almost but there doesn't seem to
be a sense of panic South Koreans have
been through these kind of outbreaks
before they've had they've dealt with
MERS for example from the Middle East
which was a very deadly outbreak that
claimed a number of lives so they know
what to do they do seem to heed the
warnings they're here in the city of
daegu the streets have been eerily quiet
as people have basically stayed indoors
they also the government made an appeal
this being a Sunday you'd expect to see
church services take place throughout
South Korea and we've specially in the
southeast of the country all the
churches seem basically to be locked
shut
people have heeded that warning they
have stayed away from crowds the
government's also urged the same to hat
take place in Seoul of weekends we have
large rallies large gatherings but a
number of political parties especially
those opposed to the government it seems
have gone ahead with their rallies it
seems even the coronavirus doesn't get
in the way of politics here in South
Korea that is so true robbed and bribed
live for us in Daegu Rob thank you